the vast majority of the business  success is actually doing all the stuff  that you know you should be doing but  you aren't Mark Zuckerberg didn't have  side hustles if you do one thing and you  do it right you do it all the way you  can get as big as you want you could  have whatever type of business you want  that covers everyone success comes down  to doing the obvious thing for an  uncommonly long period of time without  convincing yourself you're smarter than  you are it's the details that pay the  dividends it's the depth and the Nuance  of understanding how to do something  being Advanced means that you never  don't do the basics if you're like well  Alex that's going to take so much time  for me to do each of those things  welcome to building a big business  because big businesses do the same  things little businesses do but they do  them better and more